my name is mark Cerny and I'm the lead
system architect for PlayStation 4 you
know there's so many places you can play
games today historically that wasn't
true if you go back to the early
nineties Tetris sold 30 million copies
on Gameboy was a killer application
today games can be played on tablet
smartphones portable consoles home
consoles PCs and to get the attention of
the development community is very very
difficult my name is Andrew house and
I'm the president group CEO of Sony
Computer Entertainment the division
that's producing the PlayStation 4 I
think you know the PlayStation 3 was an
extremely ambitious and absolutely
superb piece of technology having said
that it came with some inherent
challenges on the business front we
looked at PlayStation 4 I think there
were several sort of key principles that
influenced our design and some of it I
regard is getting back to the very best
of the PlayStation DNA when PlayStation
3 wrapped we all started to do
post-mortems
it had been pretty brutal frankly the
hardware was very very hard to use for
the developers and I just couldn't stop
thinking maybe there was a different
path maybe there was a hardware that
could be made where it would be more
natural to make the games
hi I'm Shuhei Yoshida I'm the president
of worldwide studios for Sony Computer
Entertainment because games are being
getting bigger and bigger and the games
teams really wanted an ease of Europe
meant at the very low end and really
focus wanted to focus on making game
itself so you know ps3 is very powerful
but it's the architect is so unique that
you know by Indian team had to spend a
lot of time specifically working on
architecture I ended up kind of throwing
my hat in the ring and just proposing to
Sony Computer Entertainment that I would
lead the PlayStation 4 hardware project
he has extremely deep technical
knowledge and therefore commands the
respect of engineering teams on the
hardware and architecture front but he
is as everyone knows him best also a
really talented and very successful game
developer this was beyond unusual this
was in many ways crazy needless to say I
was very surprised when they they said
yes that I could go ahead and take on
that role for the project I suspect
though what was key simply was that we
reached the point in games overall that
it was appropriate to bring the software
creators into the room when the hardware
was being designed ultimately it's all
about having the best games on the
platform
the
short-term we can expect some very good
games long-term I think we can really
look forward to the growth in games I
mean there's a lot of untapped depth in
the hardware but any eyes would go
forward year three year four I really
believe that we're going to see on those
techniques used to make the games of
course more graphically attractive but
also make the worlds richer and more
interactive
[Applause]
we
well I mean the concept with knack was
really about creating a mash-up between
a Pixar style family film and a
character action game based around this
very unique character cold on the
hardware side we are benefiting from the
power in the PlayStation 4 the game runs
full HD so it's 1080p native we aren't
scaling it up and we have a character
that's driven by 5,000 part custom
physics simulation and there's a lot of
detail in those images we'll learn a lot
more about what can be done with
Playstation 4 once we get a look
[Music]